vous a préparé une petite compil des
clash on va cueillir raymond qui était
avec nous bien sûr ce soir
regardez la compil des clashs de ce soir
c'est baba c'est du bourg sosie
j'entends quand même des choses qui sont
aberrantes faire long jusqu'à jusqu'à
quand on va tester la limite des
français ont l'énorme ça écoute moins
deux secondes il passe à mardi écoute
moi je suis sûr qu'il va y avoir la
moitié des gens comme la dernière fois
qu'ils vont dire que c'est possiblement
venues de chine et possiblement une
guitare le nom non mais non de l'origine
papadimas on est sûr que ça le sens que
j'en arrive ça de gilles verdez qui dit
que des conneries
ouais non mais ouais on n'est pas là
pour tuer les journalistes gênants bien
aux jambes nature etc et rencontres de
ce que tu dit à dire que dit ok la
première les premières caricatures
quatre heures après en haut ils l'ont
bien cherché
d'ailleurs j'ai parlé nous de chercher
ses pas il cherchait jamais je n'aurais
pas dû le dire comment ils ont osé le
refaire voilà mais avec plein de flash
alors inquiété le meilleur des batteurs
pour vous pendant cette ce confinement
valérie bénaïm pour moi j'avais deviné
tout studio bungie à moi bien sûr mais
seront jean michel raymond ray ban